The path to successful school reform is
that of what I call "little r" school
reform. It starts with a simple premise:
those responsible for doing the work
should be empowered to do the work. When
I was hired to teach high school in
Baton Rouge, Louisiana, I offered to pick up
a set of intro economics textbooks at a
buck-a-pound book sale, I got
admonished for asking the question
before I filled out the requisite
paperwork. This is daily life for far too
many of our nation's teachers. Before
they can even focus on solving problems
for kids, they have to live in fear that
they're going to get in trouble for
trying to be smart about how they're
serving kids best. The solution really
is the path of "little r" reform. We need
to rethink systems and policies so that
those asked to serve and educate kids
are empowered to make the decisions they
need to make, and then held responsible
for the results. It might be more
frustrating to trust educators in
communities across the land, but it's a
lot more successful and promising
than leaving that authority with
self-important officials, whether they
work in the federal government or some
big dollar foundation.
To learn more about my take on the promise of "little r" reform,
check the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.